uh what do you think about starlink
and the efforts of starlink to put a
very large number of satellites
out there and provide internet access to
uh
to anyone to anyone generally I think
starlink is phenomenal and I would be
saying this if it was any company I want
to make that clear that people think I'm
just some you know SpaceX Fanboy or
something I think it's perfect I think I
think as you're a fan I could say you're
basically a fan a fanboy or just a fan
of everybody that's doing space though
and I don't like there's no even in this
whole conversation there's no way we
cover like 10 of what I wanted to talk
to you about so we're jumping around I
mean there's we could talk probably for
not an hour about Artemis uh we could
talk about anything with Ula obviously
the all the other all the other
commercial efforts we could talk about
the NASA efforts the you know the I mean
yeah and Saturn fight like are we gonna
really go with this conversation I'll
talk about satisfied and we might okay
so like Anyway star fan of everything
starling
is in general exciting to you and not
for the space assets but just the
potential for Humanity like I I really
think even as a consumer of the internet
personally our studio space down in
Texas we're stuck with with MediaCom
which has like the least reliable
internet service period That's the only
option either that or they're trying to
charge me like twenty thousand dollars
to run a fiber optic cable like a
thousand meters or something like it's
it's insane I'm not going to do that I
bought starlink it helps but it's still
not you know amazing but it has you can
see where this is going in a year two
three five years like oh I can totally
screw this other internet provider and
this is now by far the best option and
it's available literally anywhere you
don't have to be limited to your
internet's local internet service
provider
um and and on the global scale of course
you have you know people be able to
learn and learn about rockets and learn
about uh water management and
architecture and City Planning and
fitness and health all the all of the
modern conveniences that we Google every
single day there's people that don't
have access to that right now you know I
I'm a self-taught rocket nerd I would
not be who I am if it wasn't for the
internet in the last seven years you
know six seven years so unlocking the
intellectual potential of places like
Africa of rural areas that don't
currently have internet access
um that's a genuine that's a huge thing
that's like humanitarian 101 is give
people access to information and you
like you know I think we have this uh
potential to try to step in and fix
other people's problems but the reality
is like people are smart no matter where
you are you give them the resources to
learn they're going to solve problems
they're going to problem solve they're
going to engineer they're going to but
if you don't give them access to that
information they're going to be stuck in
there
and their Cycles you know and so I I
think the potential for starlink is
incredible I think it's already
impactful it's already affecting
people in you know in Rural and
Indigenous areas and it's already
affecting businesses and all that stuff
I think it's great I think it
is
you know there's some downsides with
astronomy with with ground-based
astronomy that it can hinder uh
observations from the ground
um there's already a lot of
communications between SpaceX and um
astronomical societies and things like
that because it is a real concern you
know it's it can ruin observations it
can ruin data but like one of the big
ones for instance recently I think a new
thing they're going to be working into
is that currently if a starlink is
flying over
um over a ground-based asset a lot of a
lot of ground telescopes actually have a
laser that goes up and it measures the
atmospheric Distortion and the
telescopes literally sit there and like
by the millisecond fixes like changes
the focus and fixes those atmospheric
distortions and that laser can interfere
with satellites so previously I I'm
pretty sure that SpaceX actually had to
you know request that as they're flying
over these satellites they are these
telescopes they turn off the laser and
when you have tens of thousands of these
things flying it's you're going to be
turning off the laser more than it's on
you know and just being this insanely
inconvenient thing because you're gonna
have these Junctions happen often and I
think one of the things that SpaceX is
like okay no no you guys keep the laser
on we'll deal with your laser
um good good step you know things like
that mitigating the brightness of them
so they're not visible under most
conditions of course like there's still
always going to be visible in some
um but then ultimately for me it's like
this you have this weird like almost
like a puberty of space flight and and
astronomy where currently it's not cheap
enough to really do a ton of incredible
science or space-based telescopes you
know we have web we have Hubble we have
uh you know all these other
you know awesome space-based telescopes
um Chandra you know
Etc et cetera whatever and
you uh is but it's still so expensive to
launch them yeah that were still so
reliant on our ground telescopes but in
the future you can see a world where oh
this is so cheap we'll just launch like
we can launch 50 James Webb Space
Telescope size telescopes this year for
half the price of doing it on Earth you
know and get way better data so in the
future I think in 20 30 years we'll look
at it and be like oh man that was an
awkward time where space assets were
interfering with us astronomy but I
think in the future it's like can you
imagine doing space you know astronomy
from the ground